good morning John good morning Hank
where are its for dhalsim we must be at
the dftba.com warehouse whoa
where's the caravan camera that's
question to say that it's it's it's it's
it's question Tuesday the day that we
answer it it's question Tuesday the day
that we answer we're gonna leave all of
those in I know you know it's question
Tuesday the day that we answer real
questions from real nerdfighters
you sure you don't put this on mine I'm
sure I've just asked on Twitter if
people have any questions for us John
would you like to answer some questions
for people yes that's how question
Tuesday and Friday Jessica would like to
know what were your first cars
microscope was in 1991 Volvo 240 named
whoa that was my first cartoon actually
after Arlo got the same car again but
white-wine smelled more like vomit tank
how after so long have you guys not
gotten tired of each other oh I'm so
tired of you my question is how after
all this time have you guys not gotten
tired
John yes evylyn would like to know how
do you find a nerdfighter at your
university one of my favorite ways is to
wear some kind of a nerdfighter clothing
because that tends to attract them lots
of colleges now have nerdfighter clubs
and if you don't have a nerdfighter club
at your university you should start one
you can start one Michaela asks who is
playing Margo in the Paper Towns movie
Hank I am jess we have been begging Hank
there is no other Margo Roth Spiegelman
that's what we've been saying it's not a
passion project for Hank I'm just really
not interested in the project itself
surely financial I'm the Nic Cage of
John Green movies I'll do any John Green
movie as long as you pay me enough for
Nic Cage I have a huge Nic Cage fan
actually this wood is fake that
Christopher Walken
no that was Nic Cage from Jack Jack no
sir how about you sing the answer to the
next question yes hey John yes Beth
would like to know will she be able to
buy one of those posters you signed yes
Seth how you sing we're at the warehouse
right now because John's been signing
posters all day and I've just been
watching em by the way dftba.com ain't
gonna do with it or just go to dftba
calm you can just type it just five
letters santa asks any advice on
strengthening relationships between
siblings make
do blog together I am a big believer
actually in shared projects like Hank
and I are a lot closer because we do
stuff together I think that goes for
most relationship Henry and I were just
making Legos yes Oh father-son he wasn't
really doing anything right you made
Legos and he was like go dad
do it and then he would be like that's
the bad guy and I'd be like oh no I mean
aren't villains complicated is it you
know we don't know that person's
backstory we need to learn to imagine
them complexly and Henry would say he's
really bad question yeah tell me some
more cute stuff Henry's I won't tell you
one more thing
well we're emphasizing learning how like
knowledge is power Henry said to Sara
the other day you know it's a good kind
of learning and Sara said one and Henry
said learning how to turn on the TV
how does Henry feel about me is he a fan
of thing yeah no he said right before I
left to come out here he said I'd like
you to give a message to uncle Hank and
Auntie Catherine waiting you know I was
waiting like I love them I miss them I
can't wait to see them he probably
watched my videos and he knows that
that's how I talk John yes thank you for
doing question Tuesday with me it has
been my pleasure I'll see you on Tuesday
but also now that's good but hope is not
crazy I love an ironic enthusiasm how do
you express you an ironic enthusiasm
generally some version of that sometimes
it's in turn can I try yeah that's much
better than your Nicholas Cage
impression now you have to put it in the
video